so we're getting a Stargate movie
let's talk about that welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
before we get into this video I'd like
to invite you to join our Discord server
with over a hundred people in there
we're already talking about their
favorite science fiction television
shows from Stargate to Battlestar
Galactica and more
join the conversation now by heading to
dsc.gg forward slash Sidetrack or check
the links in the description so last
week just like the rest of you I found
out that we are getting a Stargate movie
Jay didn't tell me about this prior
um he in fact teased me about this via
instant message uh saying that he had
some very juicy information and even
when pressed he basically told me no I'm
not going to tell you I'm going to tell
you on the live show so I can get your
genuine reaction
now on that live show
I did say I was going to make a video
this week with my genuine thoughts
because the thing is hearing that
information
straight away I wasn't able to process I
wasn't able to decipher how I was
feeling about it but I've had a week now
I've had a week to figure out
how I feel about a Stargate movie
so let's talk about that
as soon as he told us all that we're
getting a Stargate movie the decision
has been made by Jennifer sulke a
directive has been sent Stargate movie
go ahead with it we're gonna push on
my instant thoughts were that of a
feeling of dread
and that's because of things that have
happened in the past
now
if we take a look at the history of
Stargate I'll explain why I have a
feeling of dread and hopefully it will
make a little bit of sense to you if we
look at the history of Stargate we had a
lot of movies that just never came to be
we had the original 1994 movie that
obviously came out and that kickstarted
the original franchise subsequently
subsequently we had sg1 SGA SGU and we
had some director DVD movies on the back
of those
the actual Cinema releases we never got
anything
there was a plan and it was actually
green lit with Dean Devlin and Roland
amrick back in 2015 ish time where they
were originally they were basically
going to redo their original idea where
they would remake the original movie
they would then make the second movie
and the third and have their Trilogy
realized
now that was actually greenlit that was
announced and that was going to happen
but for some unknown reason it all fell
through at the last minute we then very
recently heard that Bad Robot were in
Pitch meetings or at least had submitted
a script outline to Amazon and MGM with
their ideas for what a Stargate movie
could look like now we have the outline
for that and I absolutely hated it I
mean I know a lot of you guys hated it
everyone who seems to have read that
outline hated it for one they decided to
bring back ra as the main antagonist
they then decided to kill off Jack which
I will never ever forgive them for even
suggesting that
anyone who watches live shows you know
how passionate I get about that you do
not kill Jack don't kill any of the
original four
just just let them be alive somewhere in
the in in the continuity of the show
they don't have to be in the show but at
least let them be alive and let them
enjoy their lives don't kill the
original four none of them none of them
now thankfully the Bad Robot script is
done it is not happening Amazon's
basically said they didn't like it just
like the rest of us we hated it and I'm
so so thankful that that is not going to
happen
but I mentioned that
my initial thoughts were a feeling of
dread and it's because of those things
that have happened in the past
we never got the original trilogy We
Could Have Had a Bad Robot script which
would have just not been good for the
continuity of Stargate it wouldn't have
been good for
at least in my opinion the future of
Stargate so when they say we're gonna
make a movie I instantly thought of
those situations and it gave me a
feeling of dread now if you are a
regular side tracker and you subscribe
to science the second channel for Side
Track you'll know that Jay made a video
on Saturday actually with a little bit
of an update with the with regards to
the movie and
this is something that I did know about
um I have I'm in contact with the same
people that Jay is uh largely there are
a few that I'm not uh but this person I
I am in touch with so I saw this message
come through
and it was very very exciting and gives
me a glimmer of hope
for the movie now the the news was
essentially that Daniel Jackson Michael
Shanks and Samantha Carter Amanda
Tapping had been approached to work on
the new movie and subsequently the
television series moving forward
now this has given me
a lot more confidence in the idea of a
movie
when it pertains to Stargate
having at least two of the original
characters
um Samantha Carter was always one
who saved the day on countless
situations and without her
you know Earth would probably have been
destroyed long ago and without Daniel
Jackson the entire Stargate program
wouldn't even have existed with Daniel
Jackson having decided the symbols when
he did and we went to aberdos
subsequently
everything that happened was a direct
result of him now we know from a
parallel world that if it was Samantha
Carter who had deciphered the symbols
that eventually the path they were on
would have led to the destruction of
earth when Apophis decided to attack
with his huge Fleet so having Daniel
Jackson back is always has always been
at the top of my mind it's always been
if you're going to bring anyone back you
have to bring back Daniel Jackson
because he is the heart and soul of
Stargate not having Amanda Tapping back
is just the icing on the cake because
she's not only one of my favorite
characters in the show she's also one of
the cleverest people in the entire
galaxy so she can drive forward and push
forward the technological advancements
of the Towery but it means we'll also
get to see things like her becoming a
general and will also potentially get to
hear what happened to Jack did they end
up together did they not and we'll get
to actually get a definitive answer now
hopefully if Amazon and MGM have been
listening and they actually watched a
show then they'll know
that they would have got together
but we do want visual confirmation of
this or at least an audible confirmation
from Amanda Tapping herself within the
show that would be good
I have been very vocal on this channel
that I wanted a series before I wanted a
movie and and even a couple of weeks ago
I made a video where I basically argued
that we needed a series before a movie
to kick start the new franchise and I
still believe in some of those
some of those points that I made I
genuinely believe that a series would be
better because the original Target movie
was fine I I really liked it but what
made Stargate Stargate was the series
Stargate sg1 literally laid the ground
groundwork for everything within the
Stargate
Universe not the show the actual
universe and an SGA and SGU expanded on
it and
that's what I fell in love with so when
they said they wanted to make a movie it
was like but I really want a series but
the thing is we now know that after the
movie they're gonna follow on with a
series so realistically we're all gonna
get what we want the people who really
wanted a Stargate movie
they're gonna get one and then we're
gonna get a series directly after it as
well and I think it's a good thing
overall because
a movie is
a movie is gonna be better
in terms of getting people interested
and getting people excited about a new
franchise
there will be people that watch the
original 1994 movie who probably didn't
watch sg1 SGA or SGU
uh who will go to the cinema to watch
this they might subsequently watch sg1
SGA and SGU in preparation for the new
series and that can only be a good thing
getting more eyes on the franchise
my only worry and this has been the only
worry I've I've had throughout this
entire conversation is if they make a
movie and it flops
does that kill
the future of the franchise
now that we know that there's going to
be a series directly after it those
risks are slightly mitigated
however they are going to want to make
more movies moving forward
and the series
might lack because of it but who knows
I'm literally just spitballing with
ideas that have been floating around in
my head for this past week things that
concern me things that excite me and
overall
overall I am excited that we're gonna
get started
any form of Stargate is something I'm
always going to be on board with
whether it's a TV show which I really
want whether it's a movie which I'll
still watch because it's Stargate or
whether it's a web series like Stargate
Origins but not like Stargate Origins
if it's Stargate I'm going to watch it
because I absolutely love this show it's
one of my favorite in fact it is my
favorite show of all time and yes I am
someone who loves Doctor Who but
Stargate has always been and
consistently has been one of my favorite
series and something that I have
re-watched over and over again and never
gotten bored so whatever they make
whatever they do I'm gonna watch it and
I'm gonna be excited about it yes there
are situations that would be more ideal
to me but I am excited and I am very
very happy that something has been
decided and we're gonna get started back
on our screens
what I want to know is what you think
there are you excited about the
potential of the Stargate movie what do
you think this target movie is even
going to be about are you excited that
Daniel Jackson and Sam Carter are coming
back as well potentially if they say yes
who should the antagonist be I think
Anubis would be a really good antagonist
because he could potentially be coming
back maybe I'll make a video on that in
the future maybe it's a new threat
whose script are they gonna use is it
going to be a brand new one are they
going to use Brad right script the
possibilities are endless and I really
want to know what you think so let me
know in the comment section down below
and if you are new to the YouTube
channel make sure you hit like And
subscribe and press the Bell
notification so you don't miss a single
video
if you want to become a fully fragile
tracker then consider becoming a patreon
patreon.com forward slash sidetrack
thank you so much for watching my name's
been Matt and I will see you
next week
foreign